In this video, we'll discuss
how radiation therapy can
be framed as an
optimization problem.
The data's collected in the
treatment planning process,
which starts from a CT scan,
like the one you see here,
on the right.
Using a CT scan, a
radiation oncologist
contours, or draws
outlines around the tumor
and various critical structures.
In this image, the
oncologist would
contour structures like
the parotid glands,
the largest of the saliva
glands, and the brain.
Then, each structure
is discretized
into voxels, or volume
elements, which are typically
four millimeters in dimension.
The second image here shows
a closer view of the brain.
You can see the small
squares, or voxels.
Here, they're two-dimensional,
but in reality they
would be three-dimensional.
Now, we can compute how
much dose each beamlet,
or piece of the beam,
delivers to each voxel.
We'll start with
a small example.
Suppose we have nine
voxels and six beamlets.
Our voxels can be
categorized into three types:
the tumor voxels, which
are colored pink here;
the spinal cord voxel,
colored dark green;
and other healthy tissue
voxels, colored light green.
So we have four tumor voxels,
one spinal cord voxel,
and four other
healthy tissue voxels.
We have two beams that are
each split into three beamlets.
Beam 1 is composed of
beamlets 1, 2, and 3,
and comes in from the right.
Beam 2 is composed of
beamlets 4, 5, and 6,
and comes in from the top.
Our objective is to minimize the
total dose to healthy tissue,
both to the spinal cord and
to the other healthy tissue.
We have two types
of constraints.
The first is that the
dose to the tumor voxels
must be at least
7 Gray, which is
the unit of measure
for radiation.
Our second constraint is that
the dose to the spinal cord
voxel can't be more
than 5 Gray, since we
want to be careful to
protect the spinal cord.
We know the dose
that each beamlet
gives to each voxel
at unit intensity.
This table shows the dose
that each beamlet in Beam 1
gives to the voxels.
Remember that this
is at unit intensity.
If we double the
intensity of the beamlet,
we double the doses.
The dose to each
voxel can depend
on how far the beamlet has to
travel, or the type of tissue
that the beamlet has
to travel through.
Similarly, we know the dose
that each beamlet in Beam 2
gives to each voxel,
again at unit intensity.
The dose depends on the
direction of the beam
and what it travels through.
Putting these
tables together, we
can write out our
optimization problem.
Our decision variables are the
intensities of each beamlet.
We'll call them x_1, the
intensity for beamlet 1, x_2,
the intensity for
beamlet 2, x_3,
beamlet 3, etc.,
all the way up through x_6.
As we mentioned
before, our objective
is to minimize the total dose
to the healthy tissue, including
the spinal cord.
So we want to minimize the total
dose beamlet 1 gives to healthy
tissue, which is (1 + 2)*x_1,
plus the total dose beamlet 2
gives to healthy tissue,
which is (2 + 2.5)*x_2,
plus the total dose beamlet
3 gives to healthy tissue,
which is 2.5*x_3.
Now for beamlets 4, 5, and 6,
beamlet 4 just gives one dose
to healthy tissue, beamlet
5, 2*x_5, and then beamlet 6,
we have (1 + 2 + 1)*x_6.
Now for our constraints.
First, we need to make sure
that each voxel of the tumor
gets a dose of at least 7.
Let's start with the first
tumor voxel in the top row.
So 2*x_1 + x_5 needs to be
greater than or equal to 7.
Now the tumor voxel
in the second row,
we have x_2 + 2*x_4, also
greater than or equal to 7.
Now for the two tumor
voxels in the bottom row,
we have 1.5*x_3 + x_4,
greater than or equal to 7.
And 1.5*x_3 + x_5, greater
than or equal to 7.
Then for the spinal cord, we
need to make sure that 2*x_2 +
2*x_5 is less than
or equal to 5.
And lastly, we just
need to make sure
that all of our decision
variables are non-negative.
So they should all be
greater than or equal to 0.
Now that we've set up
our optimization problem,
we'll solve it in LibreOffice
in the next video.